okay
this is tough and uh probably i'm gonna
get lost very very soon but let's try
okay let's see if you guys can try to so
93
let's play knight f6 and well d4 g6
where the king simion c4 bishop g7
knight c3 short castle bishop g5 g6
let's see what happens e3 so knight b to
d7 my idea is to go e5 in this position
and h6 attacking the bishop now he's
gonna move the bishop
and i'm gonna go c6 in that position
just trying to keep
all my pieces together queen e7 a3
and i'm gonna go e4 here in this
position knight d2 g5 attacking the
bishop and now bishop g3 only move and
then i
guess i'm gonna play cd cd
knight b5 this looks
very bad for me right now i'm gonna go
knight f8
in that position and covering c7 which
was completely needed
and now rook c7 and i don't know what's
going on here
actually very tough now um let's just
play queen
e6 here i'm pinning my my knight from d7
now i want to continue with knight b6
followed by bishop d7 i think
position is quite playable here bishop
d7
just rook c1 just rook case now he's
going to take on d8 now he took there
and now i'm gonna play bishop c6
almost trapping the rook and i think i
have knight e8 ideas
wow 98 i think the rook is trapped guys
he has to take on c6 i'm gonna take back
and i think i'm just much better knight
b6 no
knight uh d7 covering c5
and let's see what happens b5 i'm gonna
take here
bishop takes knight f6 let's see what
happens knight h5 attacking this bishop
and now let's just take the bishop on g3
let's just play f5 here let's see what
happens
10 seconds uh bishop c6 s4 takes takes
takes takes oh i think this blundering
my queen but no problem because we have
almost no time just knh8 just rook g8
just pre-move just remove just remove
pop up